hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be wait wait what's that I'm
getting a breaking news update Fabiano
kara wanna who was previously thought to
be pretty good at chess is now yep
it's confirmed he is very very good at
chess today we're gonna be looking over
a game of fabi's from the tata steel
masters tournament which he has just
been crowned the champion of this was
his final round game against Vladislav
artemyev and we're gonna look and see
how this one played out so Fabi
apparently very good at chess responded
to Knight of 3 with d5 and after g3 97 a
little bit a little bit of a surprise
there on 97 not the most popular move by
any stretch of the imagination but
believe it or not a few good players
have actually played it such as big
names like Vallejo Punk's alex anko and
morozova CH and Gregori Oprah a Mizzou
player who's actually on the rice and so
while this move looks looks pretty
strange it's not that strange
and in fact we'll see it just transposes
to some pretty normal stuff pretty
quickly here white plays the move
c4 black takes that pawn because it's
undefended white responds with coin i-4
desperately begging black to let white
take this pawn back black plays a6
saying sure you can have your pawn back
so white captures and black uses this
opportunity to gain some queenside space
now after Queen c2 black can play Bishop
b7 and Bishop g2 you see Knight f6
castles ISA
and now d3 and so what we've ended up in
is something pretty similar to the
Catalan but not quite there are some
some very key differences here
the first key difference you might
notice is this pawn on d3 has come to d3
in the catalan obviously that is a d4
opening and the pawn is on d4 another
key difference we saw this a6 b5 push
against Queen a for c4 this is the main
line in a lot of cattle ants and so this
Queen does this little triangle dance
black expands on the Queen side but in
this case Bishop e7 has already been
achieved pretty comfortably for black
it's not always the case in the catalan
and so you might think this is a less
ambitious try than the standard catalan
but actually bringing this pawn out to
d3 gives white some some more chances in
different ways now you'll see when black
expands was c5 which is the common break
in both the catalan and this structure
there's nothing for this pawn to kind of
bite at nothing for it to grab on to so
files are gonna stay a little bit more
closed in this type of position and
it'll keep more major pieces on the
board for a little bit longer and give
both sides a little bit more chance to
kind of play with the pieces we see in
this case Fabi starts with Bishop e7 and
now white plays a four you see already
trying to break down the slightly
overextended b5 pawn it's a very common
idea that you see many many openings
when you see this a6 b5 structure a4 is
a good way to try and create some
weaknesses
Bobby simply responds with c5 taking his
Queen side space we see Knight c3 Queen
b6 is a very nice supporting move it's a
great square for the Queen it takes b5
it takes b5 rook takes a it Bishop takes
a it C Bishop g5 and castles and now
I'll play a couple more moves rook a one
Fabi plays h6 putting the question to
this Bishop and now this Bishop could
try and retreat to a square like III or
f4 or d2 but really it's going to end up
in the way of White's own pieces from
these two squares
is potentially weak to attacks from this
night and from d2 it's kind of just in
the way it's blocking this Queens access
to the e to pawn and it's not really
serving a useful purpose so in this case
white decides to capture this Bishop and
black also captures this Bishop and here
I wanted to pause and kind of take stock
of what's going on in this position so
Fabi has the hanging pawn structure on
the Queen side and that's just what it's
called when you have these two ponds
that are connected together but they're
isolated from the rest of the group
because these two files are completely
open for black and what this means is
that these pawns can sometimes be an
advantage and sometimes they can be a
bit of a weakness and that all depends
on the amount of pressure that white can
put up against them at the moment these
pawns are actually giving black a very
nice spatial advantage and unless white
can prove that they're going to be a
little bit weak maybe by playing a break
like b4 in the future maybe by just
piling up on these ponds using the
pieces unless what can prove that
they're going to be weak the spatial
advantage is actually going to give
Bobby a nice edge and I think that's
really the the character of this game
and we'll see which player kind of
handled this imbalance a bit better also
notably after Bishop g5 and takes poppy
now has the two bishops which is a
pretty nice advantage actually in this
position you'll see that the center is
actually completely open for the moment
whoops
some some funny arrows they're giving
black a nice advantage with with the
bishops we'll see in the game white
actually deviated here from known
territory there was one game previously
played by Sergey mat Cinco and webster
player iliyan is nick that went with
Queen b3 a game ended in a draw let's
not waste too much more time Knight d2
taking away the bishop pair for black
but still leaving black with an extra
bishop and now Fabi simply plays rook c8
understanding that he needs to support
his pawns from behind and eventually
he's going to look to push these pawns
to create even more space for himself
Artemyev now continued with Queen b3 and
this move was actually met with rook b8
some mysterious maneuvers from a Fabiana
Cara Juana but the fact is with Trixie 8
and rook b8 he's actually kind of drawn
this queen out to a square that isn't
quite as good at as c2 from b3 Queen's
actually in the way of its own pond a
little bit not the most comfortable and
if this Queen we're cheap to c2 I would
expect Bobby to not repeat because now
he's brought this work to be 8 from f8
kind of for free and now he could just
continue moves like 95 moves even like
g5 expanding on the Kings side just
continuing his game plan of course white
does not have to try to repeat and
instead plays Knight C to e4
Bishop's detect the bishop is strong so
we'll move the bishop Bishop e7 this
King actually steps back to g1 just
stepping out of any potential checks or
pins and now Fabiana plays a very nice
move here and I'll let you at home try
and pause the video for a second it's
not a tactic but it is a very nice move
to show what fabi's plan is in this
position and so if you want to try and
find bobbies plan the big the big
commitment he makes on this move go
ahead and pause now if you if not here I
come it is f5 f5 is actually the best
move in the position according to the
computer and according to me and also
according to Fabi
I bet and the reason for that is that
Bobby has this nice bishop but really
just this one target on b2 isn't getting
the job done and these pawns are nice
but he kind of needs these pawns here to
prevent these Knights from having any
good squares so what does Bobby do he
creates threats on the other side of the
board as well
Bishop being a long-range piece attacks
both sides of the board at the same time
and if he can create weaknesses on the
Kings side and weaknesses on the Queen
side then he'll be able to kind of
overwhelm the white pieces so the knight
has one Square to go to so it goes there
now Fabi brings this Knight to e5 buying
some potential threats h3 is why it's
choice keeping the what the Black Knight
out of these potential threats
and now Fabia continues with the move h5
keeping an eye on this g4 square and
once again threatening to create some
weaknesses
Vladislav brought this knight to f3
allowing Fabi to take because he felt
that the pressure was getting a little
bit too uncomfortable for him so he
accepts this kind of structural deficit
in exchange for getting off this night
which was powerfully placed on the e5
square here Fabi does something pretty
interesting if you'll excuse the
voicecrack Bishop f6 and Rickey one and
now King f7 and Knight e2 and the reason
I say this was interesting is because
maybe white missed a bit of an
opportunity here to play this move h4
and after h4 it's a little tough to
continue expanding on on the Kings side
you might imagine that ok Fabi continues
with with King f7 now after this move f4
white is really trying to lock down on
these dark squares to try and prevent
black from really creating these
weaknesses that he was so desperate to
to make to get winning chances that
being said white did not go for this and
instead played rook e1 and now after
king f7 you can try something like age 4
again but uh yeah I guess you can still
go for this and maybe white should've
but black is going to be creating some
threats of his own a little bit more
quickly and white has wasted some time
here so it's not totally clear if white
has time to play these moves like f4 and
get kind of a lock on the position so
instead of h4 we actually see night e 2
and now g5 and I'm gonna call this a
little bit of a mistake from from Fabi
instead of g5 I would have liked to see
this move h4 and the reason is h4 forces
this move g4 and we'll see that this is
pretty similar to what happened in the
game but the difference is now Fabi
doesn't have to capture on g4 play move
like g6
just let these pawns sit rather
uncomfortably for awhile
you can imagine Queen c6 hit some
comfortable squares rook d8 hits some
uncomfortable squares and there's a lot
of weaknesses kind of mounting in the
white camp in the game something similar
happened Bobby played g5 and white
responded with g4 but now you don't have
time to play this move h4 because G
takes f 5 takes advantage of a very
unknowing pin in the position so now
after g4 Bobby is forced to capture and
after tix he captures again and well the
position is still Pleasant there's not
this awkward looking conglomeration of
pawns on the Kings side and so it's a
little bit less less of an edge for Fabi
I think here that being said the game
continued with Queen d6 93 Queen d5
Bobby would love to see takes and takes
because now these three ponds are much
better as a majority than these two
pawns on the Kings side so instead we
see Queen c2 bishop d4 then Queen e2
then rock h8 trying to create some
threats white plays 94 buying some pawns
but now after Queen e5 there are a lot
of threats to handle here in fact Queen
f3 check King g7 and perhaps this is
kind of White's last chance to hold on I
think best was a queen g3 going for a
bit of a queen trade when there are
still some uncomfortable things in the
position for white some uncomfortable
weaknesses to handle but perhaps he's
holding on here with the trade of Queens
instead though white plays b3 trying to
hold on to everything trying to keep the
Queen on the board perhaps to make his
own threats that I'm taking advantage of
the circle anyone especially but now
after bobbies next move rook f8 this
Queen comes to e2 and there's some
uncomfortable pressure on f2 and now
Queen d5 comes as well hitting this
newly weakened b3 pawn and after rook f1
defending this f2 pawn even more we see
king g6 a simple move and after Queen D
1 C 4 is Bobby's move to break through
and this move really undermines White's
position here it was really this knight
on e4
holding everything together it was the
glue that kept White's position from
falling apart and by undermining its
protector on d3 White's position is
really going to crumble here and we'll
see it does in fact happen B takes and B
takes and now after King g2 Fabi plays
this move Bishop a seven attempting to
capture on d3 f3 is played now C takes D
three is played and after Queen a one we
see Bishop e3 trying to push this pawn
even further rook rook F to D 1 is
actually White's final mistake here he
could have tried to hold on just a
little bit more you know uh stutely more
accurately with Queen e1 hitting this
bishop and now after a move like D 2
you're simply going to take this and
while you do win the exchange
g5 falls and perhaps this would have
actually been a pretty nice try for
white Fabi kind of let him back into the
game but instead we see Rick do you one
and now after Queen C for the game is
kind of over queen c3 was White's
attempts Queen a to check ninety two and
now we see Queens c2 is the point
hitting all three white simply can't
hold it all together
Queen e5 is what white tries now after
Bishop takes d2 I hope you packed your
running shoes because now black is up a
piece White has no way to regain it but
you've got just one problem
your king is gonna have to escape this
clean so while the Queen is pretty fast
this King actually runs faster everybody
saw this entire line King g7 Queen e7
rook f7 Queen B five King f8 Queen b8
King e7 were running we're runnin we are
running we are running so fast can't
take this rook because I'll take your
rook Queen b6 I'm still running Queen B
5 here I go running all the way to not
c3 but instead c4 Queen e6 check King c3
Queen e5 check
Kings somewhere I don't even know I'm
just running Queen d5 King be to Queen B
five and this is the last move well
should have been the last minute game
Queen B five this King on b2 has
actually finally found safety we've run
far enough because you can block this
check with another check and this is
what spells the end of the game for
white black takes this rook and now this
King has absolutely no problem finding
shelter on c2 and this is where white
decided to throw in the towel so this
was a very nice game from Fabiano
actually ending the tournament with a
huge winning streak to go to ten points
in the tournament which is kind of
absurd he had some tournament
performance well over 2900 and so yes
the breaking news is true Viviano is not
just pretty good at chess he is really
really good at chess my name is Caleb
Denby thank you for joining me in this
episode of game review and I will see
you next time